l'année dernière on faisait
effectivement face à une urgence
nationale et le seuil très élevé à
respecter pour invoquer la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence
a été atteint en faisant cette division
juste un trou d'eau à cause
qu'on a vu à atawa il y a quand même
encore du travail à faire il y a
peut-être certaines
doléances voir certains blâmes qui
pourraient émaner du comité des
parlementaires mixtes le travail n'est
pas terminé pour ma pour ce que j'en
comprends au niveau politique donc si
c'est un soupir de soulagement qu'il
pousse qui se retiennent quand même
encore un petit peu de souffle
donc est-ce que le gouvernement doit oui
ou non pousser un soupir de soulagement
le rapport du juge rouleau sur la Loi
sur les mesures d'urgence donnent en
partie raison ou gouvernement mais pas
complètement pour voir ce que nos
panélistes en pensent je joins avec
Gaston gay Chantal Hébert Michel c.io.g
à tous les trois bon dimanche bonjour
donc l'opinion publique était plutôt
favorable à l'invocation de la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence mais il y avait
quand même pas consensus donc quand on
voit ce rapport-là j'imagine que le
gouvernement sentir quand même plutôt
bien Alec
oui c'est le type de rapport dont on
avait besoin au gouvernement
c'est-à-dire que le juge rouleau
explique clairement que le seuil pour
justifier l'invocation de la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence a été atteints et il
explique dans le rapport que le
gouvernement ne l'a pas pris à la légère
cette loi-là il est tenté par plusieurs
moyens d'éviter d'utiliser la Loi sur
les mesures d'urgence de se pencher sur
d'autres façons de mettre fin au convoi
n'ayant pas fonctionné ces méthodes-là
ou ces pronostic là mais on est allés
avec la loi massue donc le gouvernement
a fait son travail le juge dit ce n'est
pas parfait il y a beaucoup eu de
lacunes mais en même temps est-ce que
les critères ont été remplis oui
politiquement à court terme c'est ce qui
avait besoin le gouvernement Trudeau
l'opinion publique était déjà plutôt
favorable à la gestion de cette crise là
de la manière dont ça s'est résolu ça va
certainement rien changer là d'avoir le
rapport rouleau au contraire ça veut pas
dire qu'il y a pas des pans importants
du rapport à étudier à décortiquer pour
mettre en place puisque c'était la
première fois qu'on l'utilisait depuis
ça refonte en 1988 donc cette loi-là
soit plus efficace la prochaine fois
qu'on puisse l'utiliser de manière
peut-être plus circonscrite aussi ça
c'est intéressant mais à court terme
politiquement oui ce rapport-là fait
l'affaire du gouvernement Trudeau dépend
certains à décortiquer ce sont des
centaines de pages de décortiquer et
Chantal qu'est-ce que vous retenez vous
en feuilletant le rapidement le rapport
en feuilletant rapidement d'abord que
c'est un rapport qui répond à toutes
sortes de questions qui étaient restées
en plan sur toutes sortes de joueurs sur
lesquels on avait dit par exemple la
commissaire en chef démissionnaire de la
GRC qui avait pas communiqué son plan à
la réunion du cabinet qui a précédé la
décision d'utiliser la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence la réponse du juge ou
l'autre c'est
ça aurait été mieux qu'elle le présente
mais franchement je ne considère pas que
c'était un élément capital dans la
décision sur l'idée de plusieurs
premiers ministres provinciaux qui
avaient dit on n'a pas vraiment été
consulté on a été convoqué sans ordre du
jour et puis c'était pas une vraie
consultation la réponse du jeu jouer
c'est
les premiers ministres ont trouvé qu'ils
avaient été consultés adéquatement et de
la même façon au début de la pandémie
quand Justin Trudeau les a sont des sur
l'utilisation de la même loi pour des
raisons pandémiques à mon avis la
consultation Obel est bien eu lieu dans
le cas du convoi et de la Loi sur les
mesures d'urgence j'ai écouté madame
Normandin
peut-être que le comité des
parlementaires va continuer à se pencher
là-dessus il y a du matériel
sur lequel se pencher pour l'avenir
néanmoins c'est pas le jugement des
parlementaires qui comptent c'est le
jugement de l'opinion publique et ce ces
conclusions-là vont conforter la
majorité qui donnait déjà raison au
gouvernement et conforter surtout c'est
important le NPD qui avait appuyé l'idée
et qui avait déjà dit je voterai pas
pour faire tomber le gouvernement si la
conclusion du juge ou l'eau va dans
l'autre sens mais là le MPD peut dire
nous aussi rapport en main on n'a pas
appuyé une décision qui était abusée au
niveau des libertés civiles donc si
soupirs de soulagement chez les libéraux
soupirs de soulagement chez les
néo-démocrates aussi et Michel est
pensez-vous qu'il y a quand même des
leçons à tirer qu'est-ce que le
gouvernement doit faire avec ce
rapport-là pour essayer d'être plus près
la prochaine fois parce qu'il parle
quand même le juge rouleau d'un échec du
fédéralisme
être obligé de la de l'invoquer cette
loi là mais dans les circonstances où on
était rendu il fallait et c'était avec
cette table de le faire c'est donc qui a
eu et il en fait le détail une comédie
d'erreur surtout par des forces
policières a commencé par la police
d'Ottawa mais ailleurs aussi agressé
aussi mais d'abord et avant tout par la
police d'Ottawa qui ont conduit
gouvernement à une situation où il
rencontrait les critères de la loi des
mesures d'urgence et qui pouvaient
l'invoquer cette comédie d'erreur là il
était évitable selon le juge rigolo
alors c'est ça qu'il faut regarder
comment on va éviter cette comédie-là la
prochaine fois
il y a il y avait une manque de de
renseignements qui étaient affolant de
la part de des forces policières vous
savez
il resteront pas longtemps mais il y a
des réserver des chambres très longtemps
toutes sortes de choses comme ça qui est
policiers va dû savoir et qui n'ont pas
su et
ça mener à l'invocation de la loi à la
fin c'est le meilleur rapport que le
gouvernement pourrait espérer avoir dans
sa constance c'est quand même assez
révers
je voulais juste mentionner il y a quand
même
entière vraiment mal dans ce rapport et
peut-être qu'on peut dire les absents
ont toujours tort mais c'est le premier
ministre de l'Ontario monsieur Ford
dans le commissaire dit c'est troublant
quand même
son absence de du premier plan de la
gestion d'une crise qui se passe dans sa
cour à Ottawa et rapidement pour mémoire
ça fait partie de la province l'Ontario
rappelez-vous monsieur Ford avait refusé
de témoigner devant la commission
peut-être qu'il s'en serait un petit peu
mieux de Siri s'il était allé
s'expliquer vous dites Chantal les
absents ont toujours tort moi j'aimerais
vous parler d'un autre personnage
politique qui était présent ce qui était
présent qui est allé donner des baignes
aux manifestants pierre poillief qui a
commencé sa course au moment où il y
avait le convoi de camionneur que les
rues étaient bloquées à Ottawa est-ce
que ce rapport-là allait peut changer
quelque chose pour lui un impact
quelconque sur son leadership
il aurait eu un grand gros impact pour
lui si le juge Roulot avait conclu du
contraire on aurait pu brandir le
rapport en disant vous voyez le
gouvernement a été liberticide est allé
trop loin et même un juge le dit et là
on aurait pu faire beaucoup de chemin
avec ça on ne va pas changer chez la
base conservatrice le pignon qu'on avait
je pense de ce qu'on voit là de la
gestion du gouvernement quand on regarde
les sondages il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
conservateurs qui jugent le gouvernement
n'aurait pas dû utiliser cette loi là
que le gouvernement dans le fond est
responsable de par sa gestion de la
pandémie de l'occupation du centre-ville
d'Ottawa je ne pense pas que le rapport
d'un juge va changer la perception de
cette base là donc pour Pierre poliev je
pense pas que ça fasse une très grande
différence l'impact aurait été l'inverse
où l'on aurait pu l'utiliser maintenant
on va réagir on va dire que le
gouvernement avait d'autres moyens on va
utiliser que le gouvernement devrait se
préparer davantage différemment pour la
prochaine fois je ne pense pas que ça va
avoir un impact particulier sur pierre
poilue je vous emmène sur un autre sujet
qui s'est déroulé à Ottawa plutôt cette
semaine la loi sur la réforme de la Loi
sur les langues le projet de loi de
réforme de la Loi sur les langues
officielles on va écouter des extraits
ça va vous donner une idée du désordre
qui règne chez les libéraux
[Musique]
jusqu'à maintenant je suis pas certain
qu'est-ce qui va se faire je n'ai pas la
version finale il y a des amendements du
bloc tu Parti conservateur qui qui
met une complètement l'esprit de la loi
non mais il y a des discussions c'est
normal c'est normal c'est normal qu'il
est déduction mais le projet définissant
il va passer c'est un très bon projet
c'est très très bon Michel est-ce que
Justin Trudeau a perdu le contrôle de
son focus
jusqu'à certains points oui à un certain
membres de son cocus en tout cas et à
chaque fois qu'on touche à la minorité
anglophone du Québec il y a des voies
qui se font ça qui sont atteindre qui
rappelle un discours que qui avait cours
beaucoup il y a plusieurs années mais
qui devraient pu avoir un cours
aujourd'hui
à chaque fois que on va proche de ça de
dire la minorité anglophone du Québec
n'est pas dans une situation miroir avec
les minorités francophones au Québec et
c'est ça que les livres blancs madame
Jovi c'est ça que le projet doit dit ça
crée à l'intérieur de la communauté avec
la forme du Québec des normes et les
députés qui s'opposent à ça sans le
reflète de la communauté jusqu'à un
certain point sauf que excusez-moi mais
je veux ça tombe sous le sens que la
situation des anglophones au Québec
n'est pas celle des francophones au
Québec que s'il y a une langue qui est
en danger en Amérique du Nord c'est pas
l'anglais alors un moment donné
entendu beaucoup ce refrain-là au cours
de plusieurs années depuis l'adoption de
la loi 22 à l'époque
un moment donné ça fait un peu dépasser
comme
discussion qu'est-ce qui explique que le
projet de loi est déraillé comme ça chez
les libéraux Chantal
d'abord ce que je trouve intéressant à
écouter les députés Montréalistes qui
s'expriment là-dessus c'est
qu'ils essayent jamais de se dire
pourquoi est-ce que les minorités
francophones au Québec habitant ce
projet de loi là
quand la mineur était anglophones au
Québec sans penser que c'est la pire
chose au monde et se demander si ils
sont pas vraiment dans le fond en train
de dire que l'anglais au Québec devrait
être traité de la même façon que
l'anglais dans le reste du Canada c'est
un manque dominante point à la ligne
parce qu'autrement j'ai jamais rencontré
un angle québécois qui sur le fond
pouvait prétendre que la minorité
englo-québecoise était moins bien traité
que les minorités francophones au Québec
ça a toujours été l'inverse premièrement
deuxièmement une des raisons pour
lesquelles ça déraille une série de
raisons d'abord effectivement de la
communauté
québécoise est en colère en colère
surtout contre François Legault mais il
se dit les libéraux fédéraux veulent pas
nous protéger et donc se tourne vers les
élus qu'il a représentent mais également
parmi ces élus là il y en a qui font un
calcul qui m'étonne totalement c'est à
dire ils disent on a fait ça pour gagner
au Québec puis ça a pas marché dans les
fêtes ça a très bien marché
Justin Trudeau a gagné la plus réalité
des sièges au Québec même si François
Legault disait voter pour lui mais on
dirait que quelque part peut-être parce
qu'ils ont pas besoin de faire campagne
très très fort pour gagner leur siège
contrairement à leurs collègues
francophones et ils se disent on n'avait
pas besoin de ça pour gagner c'est sûr
eux n'ont pas besoin de ça si un
élection demain ils vont être tous
encore député ils vont peut-être être
dans l'opposition par exemple ils
espérait plus de sièges ils en ont pas
perdu non non pas ils en ont pas perdu
comparativement ailleurs peut-être avec
est-ce qu'il devrait y avoir un contrôle
plus serré du focus pourquoi Justin
Trudeau n'agit pas plus fortement pour
essayer d'éviter comme ça des distances
publiques
ça c'est une très bonne question à
laquelle je n'ai pas de réponse j'ai
parlé à Marc Garnaud cette semaine dans
le cadre de mon émission qui est l'un
des critiques de la manière dont cette
loi-là a été créée n'aime pas qu'on
fasse référence à la Charte québécoise
de la langue française
à l'intérieur du projet de loi fédérale
c'est un objection qui peut se
comprendre je lui demandais ce que
Justin Trudeau vous a appelé vous a
parlé est-ce qu'il vous dit quelque
chose là-dessus il nous dit non il nous
en parle pas alors ça leur donne petit
coup des franges pour s'exprimer
publiquement avec des opinions très
divergentes vous avez entendu Pablo
Rodriguez très très loin d'Antony
asfader vous avez entre les deux un Marc
Garnaud qui aimerait changer des choses
mais on sent qu'il va éventuellement
voter pour la mouture du projet de loi
qui va lui être présenté d'autres
députés qui vont probablement vouloir
voter contre alors c'est vrai que là ça
fait un peu des ordres et que Justin
Trudeau pourra envoyer le mot d'ordre à
savoir ce qui est important ce projet de
loi là pour lui et dans quel mouture
cette ce projet de Wallet est important
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup
d'amendements qui sont déposés par le
bloc par les conservateurs les libéraux
sont minoritaires au comité ils sont en
train de se faire imposer une du projet
de loi qui parfois ne fait pas leur
affaire qu'est-ce que Justin Trudeau
veut faire est-ce qu'il va tracer la
ligne quelque part est-ce qu'il va
vouloir la prouver peu importe comment
sort ce rapport-là du comité ce serait
bien de l'entendre un peu plus parce que
c'est après tout un député montréalais
juste un Trudeau de Papinou ça serait le
fun de l'entendre sur cette question là
parce que c'est vrai que aussi beaucoup
de ces députés au Québec qui commence à
taper du pied en se disant là là on en a
besoin d'une réforme la loi sur la
langue officielle quand même est-ce que
ça se met là
un moment donné on se posera la question
ouais sauf quand votre libre moi votre
libre ou on permet à des ministres de
voter contre une loi du gouvernement
dont on a parlé pendant deux campagnes
électorales sans conséquence j'ai jamais
vu ça c'est pas un vote de conscience
sur une motion sur quelque chose c'est
un projet de loi du gouvernement la
solidarité ministérielle ça a toujours
comporté de ne pas voter contre une
mesure législative de son propre
gouvernement et un des derniers dont je
me souviens qui a fait ça qui s'appelait
Joe comme outil elle veut porter contre
la loi pour le mariage pour tous de Paul
Martin et a été exclu du cabinet à cause
peut-être vous écouter Chantal mais Alex
Chantal Michel je vous remercie beaucoup
bon dimanche au revoir